listen matter with you let me show you
this works use your finger this is a
computer bar this ability here's the
question which word would your friends
use to describe you your choices Bowl
trustworthy funny serious busy or
strong-willed unfortunately for you
Barbara there's no nasty Oh Kevin you
won't be able to answer is there's no
evil oh I think for sure I'm trustworthy
oh look at that
okay so let's click guys like choose
another TV show that features a panel of
judges top chef the masked singer the
voice in RuPaul's Drag Race
Project Runway in American Idol well
that's easy I have to go with RuPaul's
Drag Race because my friend Carson
Kressley is on it it's a great oh no
that's my picture I've got to go the
voice cuz really I'm a rock star
and I'm gonna do because I feel like
people in America idolized me and I
relate which of these comments selling
points are the most appealing to you
whenever they are business eco-friendly
it's the fill in the blank of the future
great product name solves a problem huge
on social media
oh I know I'm coming all of the above
I'm going salsa problems kind of ease
unavailable things easy what's something
that makes you cringe during a shark
tank pitch awkward banter deeply
personalize the samples bad dancing Oh
over the seas thank you Robert on the
show called Dancing with the Stars
nervous speaking bad financial decision
should have been there as a small
rat-like dog I'm going with bad
financial decisions
as I'm right about that because people
over there were theatrics I hate when
people are out there that theaters
terrible and crying and yeah the fake
stuff is a half that's all right
speaking take a sharp to go in on a deal
with Oh everybody knows the answer this
one making shoes it's made Daymond John
Barbara mr. wonderful
Robert Herjavec came over on a boat with
mr. wonderful click myself oh come on
Barbara be truthful you can't do that
you would that be it's another shark
okay
not even you are that conceit click do
you know what I love most about Mark
Cuban his team Oh there hey which stick
I love that word are you totally
overseeing during a pitch mmm matching
outfits talking and unison taste test
having to try out the product rapping
and singing and children running around
oh you know the problem with the kids
you just can't get be honest yeah yeah
the parents use them
I always tell these kids if you're not
willing to drop out of school the hell
you're doing a different that's on these
children running around
I hate those little kids which of the
following issues is the biggest red flag
to you no amount of sales bad
decision-making lack of scalability not
enough equity for the amount product is
too nice no other sharks are interested
who cares whatever no I don't care
hello - sales that's too old not enough
equity for the amount because you want
to get up and be excited about working
on the dog what it says no sales what if
it's people you know I don't think about
lack of scale building because if it's a
real dog you're never going to sell any
of anything obvious going there I'm
going lack of scaleable like a dog it's
a feature not a product everybody thinks
they have these little theater they're
really product in reality their fee this
quiz is getting seriously all right
Robert
which of the following Shark Tank
product do you wish you had invested in
oh they are scrub daddy squatty potty
tipsy elves bombas socks simply fit
board ring the comfy that's a good one
rubber butt is gonna sleep styler I
regret nothing ever none of the real
winners are on this list and they're all
mine so I regret nothing
Oh mommy okay I'll go with the comfy I
wish I'd done the coconut isn't a single
one on here that's from Kevin no because
I have you know without this is this no
that was this is hogwash
where are my lawyers I'm litigating to
travel on a broom for the rest of my
life and you're Damon come on these guys
all right it is obvious to me what
happened this was Russian meddling
thanks so much I hope you had a great
time I hope you take the quiz and most
importantly why shark tank Friday nights
on ABC oh I have to deal with here
[Music]